hello
racist and non-racist i'm dave rubin
this
is the reuben report direct message for
today
may 27th in the year 2021
as always click subscribe on youtube
there's a button over there
tap the notification bell see what sort
of
magic happens with the youtube machine
today we are doing a reuben report
community q a
we got a swath a wide swath
of questions about 100 questions we
randomly selected them i glanced at them
very quickly but i don't know all of
them
and i will do my best to answer your
questions succinctly
and honestly uh first though we are
going to be talking about this white
house press conference
this morning where now they're kind of
saying that yeah
maybe that whole covid thing did
actually leak
from a lab in wuhan remember that was
what conspiracy theorists
and trump people and probably white
supremacists were saying for the last
year and a half
but now we're all kind of saying it so
you know yesterday's conspiracy
theorists are today's sane people
that's how it works but before we get to
all of that
and the q a i want to talk to you guys
about bambi you know when running a
business
hr issues can kill you wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements
labor regulations the list goes on and
on and hr manager salaries aren't cheap
at an average
of 70 thousand dollars a year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy and maintain
compliance all for just 99 a month
with bambi you can transform hr from
your biggest liability to your greatest
asset
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
month to month no hidden fees cancel any
time and if you're like me then i'm
pretty sure you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend all
your time
with hr compliance yeah that's for sure
uh
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com
reuben right now to schedule your free
hr audit that's bambi.com
ruben spelled bam to the b-e-e dot com
slash reuben
and now back to me okay we're going to
throw to some video from
this morning the white house press
conference
where uh by the way there was a new
press person there
it's not jen pasaki it's a new girl i'm
told she's the first african-american
uh white house press secretary okay very
exciting
i don't really care about people's race
i care if they're competent but
some people are excited about that okay
that's just fine fabulous wonderful
uh in any event she was asked about
what's going on
with this crazy conspiracy theory that
that donald trump guy said about a year
ago
about potentially the kovid being leaked
from a lab in wuhan china let's take a
look
another question on kovid uh
the language that you all use
specifically mentioned an accident
does that mean that uh you've ruled out
or the ic has ruled out that it was
uh deliberate or not an accident we
haven't ruled out anything yet
um again we're gonna go through this you
know this re-doubling down of another
of a 90-day review and we'll have more
to share
okay so i don't know if
kovid came from a wuhan lab i don't know
if
kobe came from a bat or a pig or a pig
that banged a bat
or any of those things we are going to
find out at some point we will find out
i've seen the movie contagion and in the
end they link the whole thing together
you figure out where it came from okay
came from gwyneth paltrow perhaps from
her vagina-smelling candle all right
um but this is really really interesting
stuff
because basically for the last year
anyone that said that this thing has
leaked from a lab or at least there was
potential
that this thing had leaked from a lag a
lab was basically called a conspiracy
theorist
they were called a crazy person as a
matter of fact facebook
was deleting posts and deleting accounts
of people that were talking about this i
have no doubt
that in the youtube algorithm there was
suppression related to this i have no
doubt
that in the twitter algorithm there was
suppression related to this well just
today now
now that the government is suddenly
saying oh maybe there is something to
see here which by the way if the
government's saying oh maybe there's
something to see here
that pretty much means there's
definitely something to see here but now
that the government's doing that well
facebook
as of this morning has now reversed
their policy and you
are allowed to talk about whether covid
came
from a wuhan lab leak you have not been
allowed to talk about it
for the last year and why i think this
story is interesting isn't
actually whether it came from a lab or
not although that is pretty interesting
and technically
if it was leaked from a lab especially
if it was intentionally leaked from a
lab
well then i hate to tell you guys but we
actually are at war with china like that
is an absolute act of war
and what do we do in a time of war i
mean this this could be
world-changingly horrific so there's a
lot of stuff that we're going to have to
talk about
related to that and over the next couple
weeks and months as we find out more
you know obviously we want to get to the
truth but look it could be possible
that it leaked accidentally and then we
have to deal with that accordingly
and the international community has to
sort of figure out how they want to deal
with this sort of thing
but if it leaked negligently
intentionally
if this was something that the communist
party of china wanted to leak out into
the world knowing that the western
countries would just
self-immolate that they would just all
destroy themselves and lock down and
wreck their economies
and all of those things and buy billions
of dollars worth of ppe
from china and get all their medicine
from china well if china did that
sort of a war without firing a shot then
we got a big problem on our hands by the
way china also
you know owns a ton of our debt right
we're in massive massive debt to china
and at some point when they call in the
tab when they're like no no no no guys
no more beers on us we're calling in the
tab well then what do we do because we
can't pay them back we don't have any
money i mean
biden just now is trying to pass a six
trillion dollar
uh budget it's like we don't even have
any money in any event for the last year
we've been told you're a conspiracy
theorist if you talk about this trump
did mention it
a year ago now the question really is
like do you trust
the biden administration to do the right
thing to tell us the right thing
and also what about all of the people in
the media
who just said the awful things about
anyone that talked about this
and also does the media get anything
right i mean this is just now another
story if it turns out to be true which
it seemingly is
leaking out like you'd leak out of a lab
it's sort of leaking out now
that this is looking true so if it is if
this is just another thing that the
media got wrong
slam the people who said it only to come
around it's like man
there's just nothing left there's just
nothing left when it comes to the
corporate press so
you know hopefully a couple people will
have their maia culpas a couple people
will admit that they're wrong
but i'm not i'm not holding any a major
hope for that
um and the last thing that i will say on
this
is that the real question here is
do we do we trust any information that
this is sort of related to the media
part of this
like do we actually trust our
administration to tell us the truth do
we trust that china's going to tell us
the truth or that the who's going to
tell us the truth or the cdc is going to
tell the truth or the
the white house spokes woman or any of
those things like this is one of those
ones where it always feels like we're on
our own and
we're in it together we're at it
together because i'm trying to work
through these things in an honest way
to process it so that you guys can
process it in an honest way but
we're in it together and speaking of
being in it together let's do a little q
a we got about 100 questions
from the reuben report.locals.com
community we tried to mix them up so
it's not all politics here we go
steven says do you feel we are making
progress
wuhan lab leak finally being covered by
mainstream media mask
mandates rolled back crt getting
squashed in some of the school districts
even biden's press secretary
getting asked tough questions what's
your sense well i like this
question because it gave me a nice
transition from where we started here
but also like
i like the idea that maybe we're getting
some momentum right now
and i didn't know it's tough it's tough
to see through all the bs
but i am starting to feel like the
pushback on critical race theory is
getting stronger and stronger you know
the clip that we played yesterday
of chris ruffo the lawyer who i've had
on the show and a buddy of mine who is
one of the leading
people fighting against critical race
theory in schools the the video of him
on mark lamont hill's show black news
tonight
where mark lamont hill is trying to
demand that roofo
talk about what's so great about being
white well it's very obvious who the
racist is and that clip
really went viral which is why i wanted
to play it on the show yesterday and i
talked about it on newsmax this morning
because it's like it's fairly obvious
who the racists are
if you really think about it not even
you don't really think about it just see
the world for what it is it's fairly
obvious that one set of people want to
racialize
everything and one set of people are
trying to de-racialize everything so you
tell me who the racists are
so i think there's some pushback on that
um i think
perhaps if we start getting more and
more information that
the the covet virus did actually leak
from a lab
then the media stop might start pushing
on the administration a little bit more
i don't have any real faith in the media
so that one
that one not too much what were the
other things that you specifically
mentioned
oh that mass mandates are being rolled
back and we are starting to open up
yeah i think that at this point like we
all sort of
even even sort of the most blue and on
kind of brainwashed people
i think in in the blue states are kind
of looking around going
all right you know it's may summer's
rolling around like we're just kind of
wrapping it up
with covid like everyone's just kind of
wrapping it up
you know like it did what it needed to
do in the system whatever the hell that
was
and we're moving on so yes you're gonna
still see a lot of paranoid people
and and people not taking cdc guidelines
and wearing mass outdoors and the rest
of it trust me i'm seeing it here
um but i think there is a push back and
and i guess the proof will be in the
pudding
from a political perspective in 2022
it's like every democrat's got to go
you all gotta go you all gotta go and as
i always say it doesn't mean the
republicans are so spectacular but
they're better than that
they don't wanna run every facet of your
life and they're not running around
pushing racism on everybody so
that's that's what we'll find out over
the next sort of year and a half i would
say
ellie shama says what are your thoughts
on the openly anti-semitic rhetoric
coming from the democratic party
there was a letter from four democrats
denouncing it but the leaders have yet
to so yeah so four random democrats
congress people
who i hadn't even heard of actually did
issue a letter denouncing the
anti-semitism in their own party it
didn't really get any mainstream media
coverage i'm guessing you haven't heard
about it
because it doesn't really excite the
media right
what excites the media is aoc and
philippe and omar saying
crazy stuff look you know the simple
fact
is the endless obsession with israel
by aoc and the progressives and all
these people
kind of tell you who they're really
obsessed with i think i mentioned this
on the show yesterday there are about 50
muslim majority nations
uh there are several dozen christian
minority majority nations it's a little
harder to calculate
there's one ridiculously tiny jewish
nation
doesn't mean it's always right it
obviously isn't doesn't mean it's not
worthy of criticism
it obviously is have you ever been in a
room with jews they're pretty critical
of pretty much everything including
israel
but if you endlessly obsess over that
country
if that's the one country out of all the
countries in the world
that you want to boycott and divest and
sanction
if that's where all of your ire goes to
the place that is the most progressive
in the middle east the place that is the
most tolerant in the middle east if
that's the one place you want to
obsessively focus on
then yeah you're a bit of a jew hater
like you are
you are i don't like pulling out the
racist card and the oh you're a jew
hater you're a
you're a racist that sort of thing but
the endless obsession with that place
says far more about the people that are
saying those things than it does
uh about israel anyway i think the ship
has sailed for the democrats i really do
i just don't think there's anything good
left there and and if there was the
moderates would be standing up and yes
it is nice to see i suppose that a few
a few moderates who i've never heard of
are are fighting back a little bit
i wish him luck i wish him luck but you
guys know my feelings on this i think if
you're an old school liberal and you're
a once decent democrat
meet the meet the conservatives meet the
libertarians like let's
let's build a country while these guys
just burn the whole thing down
uh monique says this has been tugging at
me for a while why would these blue
state mayors and governors promote
policies like you can rob stores up to
900 with no consequences
let's let criminals out of jail etc why
would they do things that are actively
destructive to our beautiful cities i
mean look the cynical
the completely cynical answer to that is
that they want to destroy
america like they they believe that
america
is fundamentally flawed and racist and
patriarchal and all of those things
and they just want to destroy america
but uh
you know i've toured with jordan
peterson for a year and a half and he
would often say you have to give the
devil
as due so i will take not the complete
cynical approach i'll try to put myself
in their positions
they believe that there are all of these
inequities in society that there are all
of these
disparities right and thomas soul talks
about this that
disparities do not automatically mean
discrimination if you want a little bit
more on that
actually you should watch my interview
this week with glenn lowery which we
just put part two
up and you can get the full episode over
at reubenreport.locals.com right now
um but i would argue that if i had to
put myself in their shoes their position
is
the system has been so corrupt that we
that it forces people to do
bad things so that the people who are
breaking
into drug stores and stealing all of
this stuff under 900
or the people who are doing petty theft
or whatever these crimes are
we sh we shouldn't do anything to them
because they're just a product of the
system
now the inherent problem with that is
even if any level of that is true
even if any level of that is true either
as a nation you have
laws or you don't i mean i know that
sounds very trumpian we either have
borders or we don't
we're either a nation or we're not but
you either have laws you don't you can't
say oh we have laws
and they're applicable to certain people
but not applicable to other people
because then you also just keep the
cycle of poverty going the the cycle of
victimhood and everything else i mean
so if your argument as the ding-dong uh
as the foolish i mean really really
foolish district attorneys
in los angeles and san francisco are
doing where you can basically steal up
to 900
worth of stuff and you're not going to
be prosecuted well is the implication
that anyone can do that i mean could a
rich
kid from beverly hills whose mom won't
buy him playstation 5
could he walk into best buy and steal
playstation 5 in four games get it to
about eight you know 887
and then walk out of there would that be
as fair as the poor kid doing it now i
know it's not always about playstation
and people tell
they keep telling us aoc always says you
see you got all these poor people out
here they're stealing food
it's very rare actually that they're
stealing food we know they're going
in to electronic stores how many videos
have you seen where they're going into
foot locker are they eating these shoes
i don't think so so the cynical version
is they want to destroy america the
non-cynical version is just that they're
extremely misguided
maybe the answer lies somewhere in
between but either way
it's like we're a nation or we're not a
nation you have laws you're not a laws
and people have to behave civilly or
they don't have to
behave civilly i think you know how i
feel about it uh talia says my boy is
six
and no knows racism is [ __ ] we've
talked about it some but
how do we give this kid the fortitude to
hold his ground
how can i make him understand truth is
steadfast when everything outside our
home
is telling him that truth is subjective
well first off
um you know i don't have children yet
we're working on it i was hoping to have
some updates uh
somewhat soon it's gotten a little
complex right now but um
i don't have kids so i can only give you
sort of
wide advice here um because i wouldn't
pretend that i can have the insight on
this that you as a parent can have
um but at the at the purely sort of
ideal level of this
it sounds like you're doing a good job
first because you're telling your child
to believe in truth and i suppose
uh that's probably the greatest gift in
some ways that you could give
your child right it's the greatest gift
you could give anyone like make them
fight for
truth but what you're saying is when you
get when you walk out of your house well
then everything is subjective and boys
are girls and girls are boys and
white people are all racist and all of
the nonsensical things that a
six-year-old would be slammed at
i would say the best thing you can do is
probably be good people if you're
i i think if you model good behavior and
and decency and a productive member of
society and you model that throughout
your family and then your wider
community
that your your child will have some
immunization
to all of the mind viruses the idea
pathogens as my friend gad says says
um they will have some immunity built in
so when all of the nonsense comes to
them
they'll be like well wait a minute i
learned this from my parents my parents
are good forthright
his people the community we're around my
family blah blah blah
and i think that's sort of the best
defense i don't know that there's a
societal defense right now
sophia says how can we reach more people
in a short period of time
i talk to people all the time who know
nothing of crt that
russiagate was a flop and think blm is a
legitimate group i do my part but we
need to get people's eyes to open
quicker
with all the censorship going on what do
you suggest i mean look this is partly
why i started locals right because i
wanted to make sure
that i would always be able to
communicate directly with my audience
and not be reliant on youtube facebook
and twitter
i just interviewed crowder this week
steven crowder he has two strikes on his
channel that means for whatever reason
youtube could just take him out like
that they could thanos him
like that right so that's why i started
locals because we wanted to secure all
of my stuff so i could always
communicate with you guys you could
always communicate with me and then we
can fight for what we believe in
and that's one piece of it the other
piece though is like how do we get more
information
out there to wake people up out of this
nonsense i mean this is
this is like the gajillion dollar
question right like how do we actually
do that
i do believe in truth i mean this gets
to the to the earlier question and it
gets to that that great video that i
showed of jordan peterson
a couple weeks i think that if you put
truth into the world just because you
think it is the right thing
it doesn't mean everything will work out
but it will be the best possible outcome
and as jordan said that actually is a
leap of faith which i love that
that way he can link truth to faith
meaning if you believe in truth for
truth's sake
that that actually is a leap of faith i
think he said it's the ultimate
expression of faith i think that's a
extraordinary beautiful way to put it
and i think if you do that we can get
more people to our side if we're just
better
i mean i can tell you this you know
since i've whatever you want to call it
shifted to the right or a more
conservative
or whatever the hell you want to call it
it doesn't even matter at this point i
although i do get into it quite heavily
in my new book which we'll be announcing
in a couple weeks
um since i've done that i can tell you
that people on the right
are much nicer they are they're more
generous of time and spirit
and they're more fun and they agree to
disagree
and i just like them more and i think
that
that's not me saying i want to be around
a whole bunch of people who think
exactly
the way i think it's actually quite the
reverse i have great political debates
with them i mentioned the other day we
had this huge party here with
a 20-person dinner party on saturday
night please don't arrest me gavin
newsom and we had people with
all sorts of political beliefs here
mostly on the right there were a couple
sort of nervous liberals you know like
they can't quite figure out what's going
on yet and they're a little nervous
you know let's not take pictures at the
table that sort of thing um
but but conservatives and the right
as a general rule is cool and fun i know
that's a very
that's a huge flip on what culture has
taught us but i just believe it's true
and if you go more towards that i think
i think you'll you'll find something
good there
uh ali says how do you think the big
tech censorship of health and medical
information will affect our country in
the next 10 years
i definitely want to do a show focusing
on this
specifically because you know as we're
finding out more about covid now
and as we're finding out that there are
you know some young people with some
adverse effects to some of the vaccines
and just all of this stuff where
suddenly you know for years we've been
told my body my choice and now it's you
must let the government
puncture you with a needle like like
just the absolute absurd messaging
that's making everybody crazy
the idea of health and medical records
that'll all be online and what hackers
could do with them
and you know if you've been vaccinated
does that get you a leg up on this job
or if you haven't been vaccinated are
they going to let you on a plane
will the government try to punish you in
one way or another i think it's an
absolutely fascinating topic actually
we're trying to i'm dealing this uh with
this with my editor right now
but we have one extra chapter in my book
which is a lot very heavy on sort of the
science of the future and it includes
a bit about this and we're thinking of
actually cutting that
chapter and releasing that as a bonus
for people that pre-order so we'll have
we'll have more on that a little bit
uh ed says what do you think about ron
desantis for potus in 24 yeah i've said
it i will support him without question i
cannot imagine
a better candidate i can't imagine
anyone more ready
to stand up to the machine the real
question i think is whether trump is
going to run
and and if he runs is is desantis number
two maybe that works
what i think would probably be the best
outcome of all is that trump is the
outsider trump doesn't run but he stands
on the outside he gets the rallies going
he gets the base excited he fights the
media
and he lets he lets desantis just walk
through the fire he lets him
be the responsible respectable statesman
he lets him say the sensible things
and then trump does the dirty work that
whether we like it or not
it has to be done and the question is
can can trump
do that and and will trump do it and
does he want to do that i don't know
what the answer is and and maybe trump's
gonna run we'll we'll
i suspect we'll find out soon enough uh
fred says wondering if you and jordan
peterson will be doing anything again
soon your conversations have been
extremely meaningful in my life thanks
for everything dave well thank you for
that fred
um i would love love love to get back
out on the road uh specifically with
jordan but also
just generally get out back out on the
road i'm talking to my agents now
about figuring out a few things i think
i had mentioned to you guys that we were
going to do a week of shows in florida
in the middle of june um but then it was
it was going to all be comedy clubs like
where you can only get like 150 or 200
people
it just kind of didn't make a lot of
sense for me to leave the studio for a
week to do that
and bring my guys and everything it just
really didn't make sense i want to do
theaters and we know we can sell out
theaters
so we're working on some theater stuff i
will be in florida by the way
uh june 17th to 20th i'm interviewing
uh the mayor of miami who's just doing
an incredible job mayor francis suarez
just doing an
absolutely incredible job of welcoming
people down there he happens to be a
republican as well and he's now
welcoming all the big
tech people it's just wonderful but i
would love to tour with jordan again you
know jordan obviously it's only
it seems like it's been a while now that
he's been back but you know it's only
really what
four months barely that jordan's been
back on the map
so i don't know what level of travel
he's up to yet we are talking about some
stuff and
hopefully we can figure out something
but i'd love to travel with them or
solo and just get back out there and see
see human beings again
and we're also we actually found a
location here in la that i was thinking
about doing a live
monthly show with about 200 people um so
like a dinner dinner and a show kind of
thing so hopefully i'll have more info
on that soon
alby says excuse me ali says when will
you bring on a guest to discuss
cryptocurrency it's part of the
libertarian movement you know i've done
one or two shows on it over over the
years specifically i had roger veron he
was the guy that sort of was part of the
bitcoin cash fork
when bitcoin and bitcoin cash uh did
their big split
but i absolutely should do more and and
you know as i'm in all of these
conversations now with locals and we've
got some really cool stuff happening
there's
they're really i mean i can't talk about
it all right now but like there is some
serious momentum
uh around like the future tech and how
we're gonna get off big tech and all
that there's just there's just some
great things happening
so we're talking to all sorts of crypto
people about payment processing and can
you do
monthly subscriptions via crypto and
tipping and tokens and all of that kind
of stuff and then there's some complex
things with the sec
and we're talking about decentralized
storage and there's all sorts of ethical
and philosophical and legal issues with
all of these things
because the way we do things on locals
i'll just give you one example that you
might find interesting
which is you know if you decentralize
storage meaning that once you put
something on the internet it's there
forever so let's say in the reuben
report community
let's say we started putting all of my
content there and it could never be
taken down because it doesn't have a
centralized server right it's on
computers all over the place
well that's pretty good because i'd be
responsible for that but let's say
someone came into the community and
because they hate me they post
something illegal or evil or just
unthinkable
well if that is now decentralized
i can't remove it so we're we're doing
all sorts of discussions and figuring
out all sorts of technical ways to maybe
have the creator be decentralized
but not not necessarily the commenters
and by the way the
uh commenters in the reuben report
community and across locals because
there's a paywall a minimum of two
dollars it's up to each creator
for the reuben report community it's
five bucks um because of the paywall we
have
basically no bad behavior i mean we have
such an extraordinarily clean system
it's it's just spectacular and awesome
uh but yes i will do more on crypto for
sure uh elijah says
who would you rather sit next to on a
plane from cali to florida
aoc ilhan omar or nancy pelosi uh
why elijah why um well aoc i think would
be the absolute worst just because of
her incoherent babbling and she has such
an unpleasant voice in the tone and the
inflection that she speaks with and
ilhan omar i might find it interesting
to talk to her about some of these
things i think she has a complete
misunderstanding of history i think
she's very ungrateful to be here
in the united states i think i could
make a good case for why the u.s is good
why her obsession with israel is is
misguided
i think we could actually talk about
some of this stuff i don't think
she's very well intentioned but i would
try nancy pelosi i guess that
well that would probably be the best one
because i would just drink whatever
she's drinking
uh you know who doesn't want a little
vodka when you're on the plane
uh linda says since you left the left
how has your family embraced this and
are they on the same page as you
um well not everybody i can tell you
that much
some of my family is i don't want to
name names but if my family members are
watching those of you on my side you
um you know we know who we are and some
of them aren't
it's caused some problems in my family
actually it's it's caused some stuff um
not as much in my immediate family but
more extended talking aunts uncles
cousins things like that
um and you know i talk about this in
don't burn this book but one of the
things that i'm really proud of that i
grew up with
is that i grew up in a family that was
liberal in the true sense
where everything could be debated and
we'd have holiday dinners
and meals and and you know everybody
would be yelling and screaming and
arguing and all these things and then
dessert was served and everyone would
just let it go like i never
once remember a family fight about
politics that leaked out
into the next day it was just like oh
we're done dessert served like okay we
disagree on abortion or we disagree on
whatever it might be we disagree on
israel whatever it is you know
and it was always fine um you know
politics has now
become something else we all know it's
become this very
uh cult-like following and it's caused
people to really go nuts
i um i've tried to make sure that my
relationships whether it's with friends
or family
are not affected by this stuff but
sometimes it's not your choice
and you know nobody wants to be a
punching bag if you keep putting your
hand out
and someone keeps pushing it away you
know at some point you just don't put
your hand out anymore
and and it sort of goes to an earlier
question i find that when you
stand up for yourself you are going to
lose friends no matter what i don't even
mean this just purely in a political
sense you stand up for yourself
you're going to lose friends you're
going to lose family people are going to
say mean things about you now in
in the age of cancer culture the mob
will probably come after you but when
you get to the other side like if they
don't kill you
and they usually don't kill you at least
not yet whatever that other side is it's
better
it's more authentic it's more real and
you will find great new relationships
and friendships
and and that my life is an absolute
example of that
um dale says when you were driving to
trader joe's the other day on camera it
looked like you were
driving a tesla if so do you love it yes
we have one car
between the two of us only we are a one
car household we do have a tesla that we
lease we've got a model
x which we've had for about three years
i think the lease is just about expired
uh the model x is the suv i absolutely
love it like
every time i drive that car i'm like
this is the coolest
thing ever it feels like you're in star
wars like
everything about it is smooth and cool
and digital and
fun and and it and the ride is just so
smooth and when you really have
open runway you can freaking explode
like you just
pulse forward like you're on a ride i
mean it's really really
awesome the one thing that i don't like
about it though is that the model x
has those falcon doors you know those
back to the future doors that pop up
this way
and sometimes they don't go up all the
way and i have
bashed my head into those doors so many
times it's absolutely ridiculous
actually a couple months ago
right when conor started conor my
director it was like his like second day
or something and we were going to a
rally oh you guys may remember this we
went to the rally
at sheila cool's house she was the la
county administrator who voted three to
two to close all the restaurants in l.a
and then that night
went to an outdoor restaurant before the
edict came
in so we went to her house we were
driving to her house to uh
to protest and uh a guy in a truck just
clipped us on the road so we pull over
and the car the car actually was okay a
couple little scratches on the uh
you know lower area but car was actually
okay but as i get out to
exchange numbers with the guy the door
the back door didn't open fully i walk
right into it
and i blood just dripping down my head
which i didn't even realize at first and
then we went to the rally and everyone
was asking what happened
anyway the tesla is very cool it ain't
cheap um
but it it really is super cool and if
you haven't been in one just you got to
go test drive one
or just find a friend that's got one and
that ludicrous mode you can we don't
have the ludicrous mode of the
the lower model but there's a button
called ludicrous mode and you press it
the car it's like it's going into
hyperspace it's just just awesome
uh adam says dave and david any fun
travel plans
uh well as i said i'm going to florida
in a little bit but that'll be mostly
mostly business and florida in the
summer can be can be pretty brutal
um well you know i'm going off the grid
in august we haven't
actually discussed what we're going to
do this time around
you know last year because of covid
there was really nowhere to go so it was
a very different off the grid i've done
four i believe this will be my fifth
year doing it
um and we were just home we actually
moved at the time so we were very busy
but it was kind of easy to be off the
grid
i'd like to do if i could do like a week
or ten days just sitting on a beach
somewhere like that would be like the
main thing
and then i don't need much more than
that i think i think i have a family
wedding one or two other
little things but for me like for the
vacation stuff you know because i deal
with politics all the time and like the
endless craziness part of the reason i
do
the off the great thing is to escape all
that so when i do a vacation i'm usually
not like oh i want to go to a lot of
museums
or i want to you know do a lot of hiking
or something for me it's like
wake up if i can like roll out of bed
onto a beach
i'm good just lay there all day eat some
fish and i'm i'm very happy drink a
margarita or two
uh tanya says so you and mr david janet
are out driving around whether it's just
driving to be driving headed
to dinner or to a party you're both in
an excellent mood and have no early
morning obligations the next day where
is this going
uh what style of music or artists are
you listening to
um here you know what i'll just pull up
my
spotify and tell you just the last
couple things in my queue here
i just clicked home so my last six
things in my queue
there's a channel on spotify called 100
lounge which we listen to a lot i think
i've told you guys i like i like sort of
ambient
soft chill beats and especially for
parties it's just great to have
on in the background uh i've got my my
frankie valley
playlist which i've got to have going
all the time i love when i'm doing my
grilling like i'm very happy with some
old-school frankie valley
the rippingtons do you guys know the
rippingtons i've i've mentioned them in
the community
a couple times before again it's sort of
ambient sort of it's sort of like
light jazz just very like mood like uppy
i like i like a lot of ambient stuff
it's funny when i listen to songs
with words i go sort of frankie valley
very strong voice or a frank sinatra
or dean martin i love the rat pack that
kind of stuff
like the crooners um but generally i do
more
uh ambient stuff uh let's see what else
i have in here i will have the rat pack
on here oh i
i do tell you the truth guys because
then in the next two ambient electronica
that's a channel on spotify i think it's
an official spotify playlist
and lounge soft house i'm just trying to
think what else if we were on our way to
a party and we're in the car and we just
want to be in a good mood
um well david absolutely loves uh
fleetwood mac and i've really really
come to love fleetwood mac also and if
you get just like the right fleetwood
mac album
they're just like so all over the place
and there's so many different moods and
all good stuff all good stuff um oh i do
have a correction a correction to do on
the fly
all right the press conference video
that we showed you is from yesterday
not today and she isn't the first black
woman press secretary the first in
decades
the first was judy smith who was under
george h.w bush i like doing corrections
for some reason
to me like that there's something nice
about that like i don't have a problem
you know i do
as much of this as i can off the top of
my head
and you know okay so we got whether it
happened yesterday or today
wrong like that sort of thing but like i
really don't mind doing corrections
i'm just a human being doing the best i
can with some paper and a sharpie
uh all right guys hope you enjoyed the q
a uh if you want to get in the next one
of course you can always join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
part two of my interview with brown
professor brown economist
glenn lowery is up right now he happens
to be
a conservative who happens to be black
and happens to not be into critical race
theory
i think you'll find it quite interesting
uh my full interview with stephen
crowder about what's going on with his
youtube channel
uh may it be here tomorrow we do not
know uh that is up right now
on both youtube and on locals and
tomorrow we're doing a news recap
panel we've got liz wheeler cabot
phillips from
the daily wire and alex marlow from
breitbart
i've got a couple other things to do
today enjoy your afternoon everybody
and uh yeah let's let's use some i feel
momentum do you feel a little momentum i
feel momentum
let's fix this thing all right see you
tomorrow